now being a man that is highly into
fitness
I had to figure out where my body is
starting at in terms of its level in
Fitness so we are going to go to body
spec so we get the body spec right I
walk in and I see this giant of a man
just standing there and it turns out
it's [ __ ] Kevin Love Kevin Love
himself
Congrats I love you shake I just shook
Emma left hand I feel good today we're
done this is get the fake no no this is
it okay take it away that's mine I'm not
saying we're best friends but we best
friends welcome everybody
if you guys just noticed I met Kevin
Love earlier it was so weird I just had
to step away cuz you were just like oh
my god oh my god oh my god okay first of
all it wasn't even like that first Kevin
Love just won his championship ring
I had to shake his hand and like I said
he shook LeBrons Han Solo Bron touch me
where are we at today Lynne we are what
are we doing today Lynne so we're
finding out if I'm an athlete or not
David definitely I don't tell you hi
well what can you tell them I can tell
you this is you this is David and for
those of you guys that don't know that
what this is
must not sponge it's muscle it's pure
muscle this is because right there let
me explain something to you right now if
we were in the Arctic and we were lost
who would you want to be cuddling butt
naked next to so body spec is basically
a lot of athletes go there to check out
how you know basically to see what it is
is that so they'll test out their body
fat kind of see where they can start in
their fitness level to see if they're
where they can improve in etc
oh my God look at this it's like
something from a was it call have you
seen the aliens movie where they're
sleeping in the pods and the alien pops
out of their stomach that could be you
so basically what I walked into with a
DEXA scan now a DEXA scan basically
measures your body fat which I'm
guessing I'm floating roughly about 12%
throw away the original keep the copy
don't even laugh it's gonna [ __ ] it up
stash off everything on her body is fake
boobs teeth nails now much like in
royalty days you never have the King go
first you have the peasant taste out the
food so I had Gio's peasant ass get on
that [ __ ] and what big eyes barely fit
fat it has to be exact
it's just finger nothing you're Mexican
see if you were a lot of story even got
a lot earlier stay forever this
machine's times like [ __ ] this [ __ ] is
tall ah you look a little T
I can't picture you with anybody but
Marcus it's like it's very difficult
that you two are body parts this not
actually later because Martin has a
big-ass head so and he's a very tiny
frame
I predict that my body fat is going to
be in like 25% for hire
I say 19.8 seven oh was it even working
fit I don't know absolutely no idea just
let you know Geo so talk we've been for
three hours
I mean clearly just by looking at side
by side I don't think she's just
finished me I don't think she's nearly
as pretty as me and also out that she's
as smart as me
so hopefully the scans gonna show how
dumb and fat she is Wow was it painless
no it's terrifying it's so scary
why just kind of judging my every two
seconds yeah I don't want to tell you
what it feels like but there's a slight
stain it feels a little bit hot you're
[ __ ] mine they'll ask her you're like
right no it feels a little bit hot all
right
yeah your father research no it's warm
you feel like I taking you in today I
don't want to boast about my fitness
level or physique but one word athlete
two words LeBron James
three words LeBron James champion how is
this possible how do you even talk about
it
think small think so oh you feel it I
told you dude I had to deflect my last
hope I saw I will [ __ ] 30 minutes
oh my god why is it gonna take so long
because of the muscle mass it's hard to
scan all those fibers muscles in your
body if you have more fat it might go a
little quicker just saying gee oh you
fat gonna burn oh it's not to have my
eyes closed I even away I don't feel
anything at all what does that smell is
that bacon
oh it feels like somebody are you
reading on you I gotta sort of God did
you guys know that this is the same bed
that Kevin Love laid on this visa
technically I played on top of Kevin
Locke basically Kevin Love and I we [ __ ]
I'm not saying that we had sex what I'm
saying is Nikki and I were both on a
machine together he was on a machine I
was on that machine our sweats touched
each other
Kevin you having my baby I feel like
this the she is trying to figure out if
I have a superhero or not it's like you
know what I had super
the day could be a disability so it's
talking to you yeah that's what the
machine saying that's exactly what she
says you it's also saying those piece of
garbage here before me
it didn't take 13 minutes though I have
never said this to anybody but madam you
are trash no that's what it's figuring
out right now is like is this human or
dissing animals my eyes would do by in
terms of fitness and health perfection
well the last time I got my body fat
percentage check was when I was like 30
pounds lighter than I am now oh cool so
it was pretty fantastic when why did you
do that well my dad wanted me to because
he said that I'm going to die you are a
pet you are going to die dang he spent
like top dollar
like literally to prove to you that I
forgot about this is critically a
conversation option just so I was in the
living room and my dad is just like
staring at me and he goes every every
time like that sees me he always has in
common by the way because literally four
baby Eagles you know you're going to die
I was like what he goes what what
happened prior to that though it was no
conversation we're sitting in the living
room and then he goes you are going to
die at something will you be because
were so fat you must come here
and I'm like why I just come here and he
grabs my stomach then pitches it to do
like the fat test this thing with his
hand yeah this is how much fat you
thought you're going to die and I got so
upset because I just said to her there's
a whole facet passed by you're growing
that was a slow fast I said it all
that was fast everything else like a
long time no a stop or say no like what
a new bows oh my god I do not want to
know my results at all why actually I do
you should know see I should've done a
few more push-ups too late for this
weapon what this can't happen who knows
there could be some extra muscle
pheromones that flight isn't the how the
body works after we got our body scan we
of course can't receive those papers
without knowing what the [ __ ] were
reading so Lin actually came through and
told us what our results were let's go
over hers first cuz like I said we need
to have a a foundation for what [ __ ] is
before you go into excellence go all the
way through hers and angle yes I want
you to go through hers first
you said yours was over 25 what do you
think yours is mine's a solid 30 35 two
hundred thirty thirty-five forty maybe
maybe 50% 50% fat hey 60/40 cuz I don't
know what a measurement of good or bad
is so I don't know what that is all I
know is that when I do jumping jacks
things shake a lot mana nation so well
with the Mexicans we're going to scan a
little bit higher fat than what you
would normally see like calipers or the
water cuz it's a liar
cuz we're able to scan more precise all
of your tissues and then we're also able
to scan like deeper layer tissue so the
fat that surrounds your organ Cheetos ha
I want to see her Spurs wait up
no but let's do a guessing game of mine
after seeing yours we said 58 what I
don't know
no of everything okay so we'll go
through this and then we'll open your
dance wall okay so this is your body
scan what you see in white is gonna be
your bone density green is gonna be your
lead to shoot those are titties
oh yeah
you know what's cool about a DEXA scan
it scans every part of your body
specifically parts that are fake so if
you look at a gos DEXA scan towards a
chest area
you'll see two white globs fake titties
green and enemy or lean tissue lean
tissues gonna include your muscles your
fluid in your organs red is gonna be fat
tissue all right so my total body fat is
twenty seven point one that's horrible
is that nothing that horrible
I think that's horrible oh uh my total
mass which is just my weight right like
everything altogether is 157 point four
yeah so we break that weight up into
each tissue so fat tissue in pounds lean
tissue in pounds in bone mineral content
oh I don't feel that bad forty-two
pounds of my total weight is uh fat
tissue and then my lean tissue is 108
pounds of that not bad geo-scan was
interesting because what it showed is
that half her body is composed of
garbage so if you're 27 point one
percent body fat could you imagine how
high my numbers to my death did he watch
your videos yes thirty five point four
percent body fat
I think the machine was broken to be
honest with you said I had a thirty five
percent body fat and I think that's like
absolute [ __ ] I think in [ __ ]
thirty thirty seven percent I just
checked that last year and I was at a
low three to four percent Lance
Armstrong same thing body scan read and
be fat to shoot greens leaves not bad
why is bone mineral content
34:45 of the facts there though so
that's the penis never watch Dragon Ball
Z well the Super Saiyan has the tail
wrapped around the stomach it's my dick
look at that lean muscle mass in my
calves look at all that Rhett around
yours fatty
true but the torso here yeah it's
basically cooling yeah I had like no fat
on my upper body it's all on my lower
back my body so down here is the body
fat percent I'll chart uh basically
where you fall among other men or women
who have and with what I suspect so up
here is gonna be the top athletes like
elite of the elite which is where I am
yes definitely Richard and then just
from here on out this athletic average
oh I'm athletic how you figure that cuz
what you what she just said this is the
top top this is athletic and then it
goes to a shame never leave your house I
think you're probably on this I'm
roughly about this right here which is
shaved right right before death right
before evaluate your life is now David
you're not a woman
okay I could be okay oh you shouldn't
you know worse it's even worse never
mind you are I'm a woman you're a woman
is this based on American based on
people who ask and with body spec so
we're it's gonna be a little bit more
biased because mainly athletes come in
here and then our trucks go out no no no
I gotta else but you're an athlete
though yes so but you can't be that's
why I'm like in the shame but I'm no I'm
just wondering if it's based on the
average human being alright for people
who are more athletic Kevin Love was
here you know I know and he and I are
very similar and by the way just to put
in perspective out there is something I
used to believe in - back in the day
where people told me that I was just
big-boned there's no such thing as big
bone dude we're just fat your bones are
smaller than mine look at how cute that
is
you know like every time cuz you know
one funny fat fit started I keep on
getting these comments like I'm
big-boned it I was like Dawg I'm pretty
sure an archaeologist when they find
people they're like damn big bone and
[ __ ] not relax dude you got
regular bones just a lot of [ __ ] around
it so we always want the waist to be
smaller in the hip because within their
waist we have all of our organs oh yeah
but doesn't that mean I'm just
protecting my [ __ ] with extra styrofoam
because I'm pretty sure when you pack
your stuff when you move you want extra
stuffing on it so you don't break the
plates or plates off of them no no
they're not you throw that stuff out and
then you reveal the pretty stuff
underneath it you don't like stored in
your house full of rats no but when you
move [ __ ]
I have to wrap it up extra nice actually
you wrap it a nice right right but then
we want representative people who do
they want thrown at it or the no [ __ ]
examine area we are talking Mariel
doesn't want that he remember the you
know Muriel does not want need to be any
more attractive because the women will
take me away she did not say that
she's always flippy-floppy bill she goes
to Bart when he was hella fit and rips
heels you're too hard I can't hug you
big baby haha big no-no maybe I did see
now you're too fed your shell grows if
he was like you all squishy it'd be
perfect that's what I want but he's not
because he's fat and he's hard you're
comfortable see first of all but let me
tell you guys can come comfortable
comfortable don't get you with me so
within the Android region we house to
Texas that there's gonna be the
subcutaneous fat you can see them blue
subcutaneous subcutaneous is the fat
that surrounds your entire body
basically the fat thing can pinch it's
right below your skin there's also a
deeper layer of fat tissue called
visceral adipose tissue we'll call that
visceral fat so that's the fat that
surrounds your organ so this is how much
you have in fat in that region lower the
better the lower the better guys have 1%
- all what else we have all your place
have [ __ ] up in your box that's all
that it means don't call it up to move
your [ __ ] cause she's just go stuff it
with nothing when I pack your [ __ ] I'm a
stuff it with hella stuff her ass over
here
nothing because it'll [ __ ] continue
the more fat that surrounds your organs
the more oxidative stress you're gonna
cause among your organs which can lead
to higher risk for disease so with Geo
yours is already pretty low so target is
zero you can have it as low as possible
[ __ ] all she eats is candy this
thing is [ __ ] up continue David my you
so but this is this is in a scale
letters to avoid giving excuse all your
big excuses I'll just say I'll protect
about plates a goal for you is just to
bring this number down and that's gonna
be via diet and exercise oh that's crazy
because I hate all that not going on a
die
but having a diet balanced diet filled
with cleavage Tibbals first over
everything else let's let's deal with
the real problem here
[ __ ] vegetables one thing that the DEXA
scan cannot determine is my heart and my
personality also my charity works so
yeah [ __ ] you what we should do as an
experiment is put on the baby so diet
and I'll do this oh you didn't know I
don't know that no one's gonna love me
anymore what are you talking about are
you saying that that people can't be
loved
oh never at jamee no don't say that
they're gonna I hate that word but I'm
gonna use it now fat shaming this is the
bulk density report so this is compared
on our national database so you see we
use your age match z-score and we match
that with other men your age and
ethnicity and do your women your age and
ethnicity and we see that David fall in
the 95th percentile so your bones are
more strong more dense than 95 percent
of men your age and this is that's crazy
cuz I fractured both my ankles oh cool
I'm part of the same percentile as David
Oh a little bit lower your legs are
gonna snap no just water percents are
you talking about oh I just want you to
get hurt it's interesting because your
whole life you tell yourself I'm perfect
I'm perfect until you see the numbers
it's not true it's very interesting
because this right here could be a lot
of different people right we're thinking
about Catherine zeta-jones perhaps over
here we have Roseanne Barr maybe John
Goodman you just Peter Griffin what
thank you
you have brought my self-esteem lower I
know do you like what you do tell me
people they're horrible well how do you
feel I feel great see that's what
matters I feel fantastic body spec is a
great way for you guys to really assess
kind of in general where your body's
adding from the fitness so if you're
trying to lose weight or you have a
specific weight goal in mind
and you don't know where to start we'll
go to body spin you can see for the
numbers anyways like an actual number
see where you're at and a good you're
productive because I feel like a lot of
times we're shooting in the dark you
know we know we wanna lose weight we
don't know how or what parts are the
parts that we should target so for me I
know that really isn't much improvement
that I can do on already a perfect
specimen
but for you guys you average bucks you
might need to really see those numbers
hope you all enjoyed that finding out
how out of shape Gio is yeah you know
what it only confirms how amazing I am
art the red parts the red parts which
was extremely bright near my penis area
but it's kind of cool because I got to
see that I am incredibly out of shape so
my self-esteem is really low right now
35.4% body well I think this is also
really dope cuz I mean you're also
pretty damn athletic and a lot of these
things did state that so for you guys it
also states that you guys should never
judge a book by its cover just cuz a
girl looks skinny doesn't mean she's fit
don't judge a book by it's cover
never David judge him hard yes I am I
it's true Olympic athlete
Oh